[Musique]
l'australie et les états unis songent à
bannir l'application techtoc pour des
raisons de sécurité nationale
l'application permet de créer et de
partager de visionner des vidéos et elle
appartient à une entreprise chinoise
mike pence
plusieurs pays craignent que le
gouvernement chinois n'utilise techtoc
pour récolter des informations
personnelles
le gouvernement chinois aurait aussi
demandé à techtoc de retirer des
publications concernant les
manifestations à hong kong est la pièce
la place tiananmen
alors la question parce que nos données
sont plus à risque sur les plateformes
de réseaux sociaux comme tectum ou
encore les autres est-ce qu'on est plus
vulnérable aussi au piratage en cette
période de pandémie
on va faire le point avec éric parent il
est pdg de la firme de cybersécurité et
vos technologies
merci d'être là monsieur parent merci il
ya de plus en plus de gouvernements on
vient de les souligner la qui se méfie
de cette application chinoise yan l'inde
qui l'a banni l'australie réfléchie des
états unis aussi pourquoi au juste
mais il ya sûrement des enjeux
politiques parce que les primes de
sécurité sur tout réseau sociaux sont
pas mal démarré mais puis tik tok et
peut-être même moins pire que certains
autres réseaux sociaux par la nature qui
collectent moins d'informations dans un
sens facebook est beaucoup plus verbal
dont tu as beaucoup plus de choses dans
facebook
toc toc c'est des petits segments vidéo
et puis peut-être la géolocalisation des
choses jardot mais c'est quand même
potentiellement moins à risque d'un
point de vue de la surface de données il
reste le fait que c est berger ou
potentiellement à sa place par la chine
c'est hébergé en théorie aux états unis
pourraient avoir un contrôle chinois
et puis là dessus et des grands enjeux
politiques quand on parle de sécurité
nationale
c'est un peu drôle il faut comprendre
que 95% et peut-être plus des citoyens
américains peuvent pas avoir aucun
impact sur la sécurité nationale
on pourrait se poser la question
pourquoi qu'on utilise ce terme voilà où
est ce que vos familles de données qui
sont accumulés lors quel genre de
données personnelles techtoc accumulent
sur ses utilisateurs vous avez parlé
viol localisation mais est-ce qu'il ya
plus que ça les tempi les sujets qu'on
va aborder ce techtoc va peut divulguer
notre opinion sa part est une opinion
politique pour être une opinion sur
n'importe quel sujet alors c'est un peu
de même que celle de l'autre version
d'autres produits longs en chine a été
utilisé le contre contre la population
chinoise
et puis ça pourrait quelque chose qui
pourrait nous préoccupe est ici mais de
l'autre côté de la médaille on a
également facebook et plein d'autres
produits qui permet un peu la même chose
et peut-être même que ça va plus loin
comme vous comme vous l'expliqué donc on
n'est pas plus vulnérables de se faire
pirater ou d'avoir nous données
accumulées si vous voulez qu'on soit sûr
peu importe quelle heure réseau social
si je comprends bien c'est que la
réalité sur le terrain c'est que toutes
nos informations personnelles les plus
pertinentes ont déjà eu une fuite un
moment donné enfin que techtoc ou
facebook au pot notre numéro 100 social
notre date de nessma données willow
mettre tout le monde doit alors c'est
simple ce qui devient un peu franchement
c'est qu'on peut on tout pointé du doigt
techtoc mais en réalité il faudrait
vraiment se questionner sur
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux en
général
alors quand qu'on aimait un communiqué
de presse qui ont dit qu une force armée
aux bannis techtoc pour des militaires
la réalité sur terrain c'est qu'ils ont
banni les autres aussi ce serait
suicidaire ou vraiment pas intelligent
d'envoyer des gens se déployer et puis
d'utiliser facebook de divulguer leurs
positions et puis de laisser déjà faire
comme ils sont à la maison je vous
entends parler monsieur parent et sa
forme vocale activement inoffensifs ou
du moins il peut plus dangereux que les
autres plateformes pourquoi ce moment là
est ce que vous avez les grands pays qui
choisissent de bannir l'application du
moins qui songent sérieusement ccc
politique c'est un dossier à la web
peut-être pas avec la même portée mais
ce que c'est le rapprochement mais sont
très décisif et c'est sur une pure
spéculation mais imaginez les états unis
ou qu'on au facebook pour l'instant ne
met pas une grande muselière sur la
maison blanche
alors là on peut parler de bannir tik
tok est potentiellement assez important
compétiteurs à facebook ça que ça peut
être une manipulation finalement
politique pour essayer de convaincre
facebook de peut-être rien faire le
domestique statu quo spéculation total 6
et 7 août des plateformes qui sont pas
très bon pour la société parce que l'on
peut facilement manipuler les gens et
puis les choses qu'on veut nous
présenter quand on regarde notre
facebook mais c'est des choses qui ont
été pré marché qu'ils y ont décidé qu
est-ce qui vont nous montrer même si
c'est pas malicieux
ça c'est donc dans nos amis on a plus de
gens qui sont contre dans notre rang
pour d'un autre homme
on va nous présenter des choses
cette saveur l'eau et potentiellement ça
ça va nous influence est un peul
argument qu'a repris l'australie disant
qu'ils avaient eu un problème avec la
modération des contenus on faisait
référence à du contenu retirer et
concernant les manifestations en compte
par exemple c'est peut-être un peu là le
noeud du problème
oui puisque c'est à dire ça devient
politique fait que si on aime poule 7
cette façon de faire alors on va pas
dire le produit c'est potentiellement
bien quand une vraie meneuse raison en
arrière oui bon les réseaux sociaux
peuvent tous être vulnérable on a vu
l'exemple de twitter la semaine dernière
comment on explique des brèches
importantes mais qui semble revenir
aussi est touché plusieurs réseaux
sociaux séquence est une plateforme qui
est très populaire c'est ce que plein de
gens qui vont se pencher sur 7,4 forme
nos bras c'est de trouver des
vulnérabilités
pour l'instant on sait pas exactement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé chez twitter
mais on a des bons indicateurs qui nous
dit qu'il y aurait peut-être quelqu'un l
interne qui a été impliqué et u qu'est
ce qu'on appelle l'ingénierie sociale ou
quelqu'un aurait été convaincu de faire
quelque chose de permettre quelque chose
et ça ça aurait donné accès à la
plateforme en arrière plan la plateforme
de gestion de twitter qui permet de
faire évidemment plein de choses comme
si on est un employé de twitter
on va voir des films dans les prochaines
semaines les vrais détails vont
peut-être faire surface mais ça va être
très modulaire ce que ça aurait eu
également c'est très politique
ceci étant dit qu'elle soit plate forme
comme twitter ou n'importe qui d'autre
ces réseaux sociaux il faut pas
s'imaginer que c'est sensé est une plate
forme de haute sécurité
j'ai voulu être quand même une
plateforme sociale et puis très ouvert
alors le fait qu'un employé pourrez lire
vos chose à dire la potennerie le
j'entends votre rappel de sécurité fait
attention à ce que vous publiez question
en terminant monsieur parent on est un
contexte de pandémie on peut pas
l'exclure est ce que va engendrer plus
de piratage c'est sûr que une vague pour
une peau dès le début ce qu'il faut
comprendre que les gens qui font du
piratage était pas non plus près avec
covile mais aussitôt qu'ils sont adaptés
à l'ast contexte où les gens travaillent
de la maison alors c'est facile
d'envoyer un courriel qui vont être dans
un bon contexte et puis qui va sembler
très le digitimes qui vont se parler
peut-être d'une mise à jour pour
continuer à avoir accès à distance à
votre bureau
et puis les gens vont tomber dans ce
piège lieu à la fois être très très
vigilant en gros on clique jamais sur
rien si on n'a pas parlé à quelqu'un au
téléphone qu'on connaît
qui nous indique que c'est vrai qu'on
devrait prendre cette action-là toujours
un excellent rappelle monsieur parent
merci d'avoir été la bienvenue et bonne
soirée